this next clip is something you should
never try at home or on a trip down the
Amazon River you're looking at genuine
piranha scissors
I can't imagine needing a pair of
scissors badly enough I'm gonna grab a
piranha with my bare hands this is all
the Piranha can do at this point it's
out of the water it's being held very
firmly so the one thing you can still do
is open and close that powerful jaw so
what's behind these destructive dentures
the reason this piranha looks like a
pair of scissors is because of a very
powerful rope like tendon that attaches
to its bottom jaw and they can bite at a
force of 30 times their body weight
which is higher than any other animal
even animals like alligators this is a
great evolutionary adaptation it can cut
through all kinds of things not just
flesh but bone you get to a time when
the piranha is really hungry doesn't
have a lot of food to eat it needs to be
able to take maximal nutritional
advantage of any animal that wanders
into the river after the incredible
display of chomping the little fellow
was put back into the river
next time he might not be as obliging so
please don't try this at home
if your piranha bytes off your finger
that happens once and you don't make
that mistake again